[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم باجاز من الغرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
خلال اقتحام القوات الاحتلال مدينه جنين
رئاسه الفلسطينيه تتهم واسرائيل بمحاولته
اشعال المنطقه بينما اكلت حماس ان جرائم
الاحتلال ستزيد الفلسطينيين اسرارا على
المقاومه واعلن الجيش الاحتلال بدء
التحقيق في سقوط خرائط عسكريه حساسه كانت
بحوزه جنوده في عيد الفلسطينيين بمخيم
جليل
السجناء رجل الاعمال الروسيه فيكتور بوت
ولعيبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتني جرايدر
حيث يؤكد بايدينا ان اعاده الامريكيه ليست
اختيارا وان حكومته ستواصل العمل على
اطلاق سراح السجناء اخرين
نائبه رئيس البيرو ادينا بولارتي تتولى
رئاسه البلاد بعد قرار البرلمان عزل
الرئيس فيدروكاستيو بتهمه تنفيذ انقلاب
اثر اصداره قرارات بحل البرلمان واعلان
حاله الطوارئ واتم اعتقاله من قبل الشرطه
بتهمي الفساد والخيانه امريكا رحبت بتسلل
الرئاسه وتعهدت بمواصله لدعمه
رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم جاني
انفانتينو يصفوا دور المجموعات في نهائيات
مونديال قطر بانه افضل على الاطلاق وجاءت
هذه التصريحات بناء على النتائج التي
شهدتها مبارياته هذا الدور وبناء على
تسجيلها ارقام القياسيه من حيث عدد
المشاهدين في الملاعب وعبر الشاشه الى
اللقاء